so tell me about this we commerce
business this is a collection of assets
that you bought and then took public how
did that all go down and
what do you actually do yeah it's kind
of a funny story i met
harley from shopify and toby as well
about 10 years ago at a conference
and at the time shopify was pretty small
i don't even think they'd raised their
series a yet
maybe 15 employees and they had a
problem which was
unless you were a developer it was
really hard to make your site look nice
and so they built a templating language
and they basically wanted us to come in
and be their first partner and bring
great design to the platform so that
with one click
anyone could install a theme and make
their shopify site
look beautiful and so we ended up
starting a business called pixel union
to do that we started a whole bunch of
uh we built a whole bunch of themes and
it was a great success and before we
knew it
uh you know that business was doing
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
revenue a month
and in 2013 i had i you know was still
running the agency
i had a whole bunch of sas businesses
and other stuff i was running
and honestly i was just exhausted and so
i decided to sell the business
uh for the first time ever i'd never
sold a business before
and so i sold sold that business and uh
when the money hit my bank account i was
like okay i need to learn
investing and stocks and all this
conservative stuff and so i picked up a
book about warren buffett
and when i read about buffett i was like
holy crap this is amazing and you know
got really into investing
and so i actually stayed on the board of
the business
uh until 2019
and i saw an opportunity to buy back the
business from the private equity firm
that uh bought it from me this is so
union
this is pixel union and so we we bought
it back this is the business we did with
bill ackman and howard marks and all
those people
and uh we bought it back and we formed
wecommerce and the idea was basically
just to
use our playbook that we use a tiny of
just buying
the best businesses and various
ecosystems
in a very founder-friendly way and we
wanted to make a long-term bet on
shopify and so
we ended up raising 60 million bucks and
taking the business public
um and now we're out there just looking
to buy more incredible businesses and
shopify
uh in the shopify ecosystem and so the
whole business just
is dependent on shopify so you
rise and fall with shopify's incredible
ascension right now
um but does that create a massive
liability or
you know um risk factor like what if
shopify
i don't know amazon comes into their
business or whoever comes into their
business it makes it more difficult for
them what do you do
well it's very much a bet on the future
of e-commerce and shopify and i think
that
e-commerce is such a massive market and
shopify is such a dominant player within
it that that's a whale i'm very
comfortable being a barnacle on
and i mean you can make the same
argument for all sorts of businesses
that are in the salesforce
ecosystem or the microsoft ecosystem at
the end of the day
you're always tied to somebody facebook
apple amazon whoever it is
and we have a lot of trust and a lot of
a lot of experience working with toby
and harley so we feel very comfortable
being a part of that ecosystem
um we recently had the pitch.com founder
on the pod
tell me about that business and what you
did there yeah christian's amazing
uh so christian and i were actually
competitors
so one of my first businesses i started
was a business called flow
which is a task management software
product for uh
teams and christian was my mortal enemy
uh we started at the same time he had
wunderlist
and one day i was in san francisco and
he happened to be there too
and so we decided to meet up for a
coffee and i walked in expecting to
stare him down and kind of glare at him
and
we just hit it off he was such a nice
guy and we've been friends ever since
and i don't know if you ever your
audience knows but he sold the business
to
microsoft and when he left microsoft he
called me up and he said hey
i've got a couple product ideas i'd love
for you to help me
build them and so we brainstormed uh you
know what's wrong with
powerpoint and came up with a whole
bunch of great ideas for pitch and then
my agency meta lab helped build uh or
how sorry helped
design the first version of it does that
mean you have equity in pitch.com you
get to participate on the upside of that
i do i do do you invest in companies
um just as a straight angel investor or
venture investor you said this have this
hundred million dollar funds raised
that hundred million dollar fund is to
buy businesses to invest in businesses
or both
yeah it's 150 million and it's just to
buy businesses
i look at uh you know buying majority of
uh or control interests and businesses
that's my primary
business uh venture is something i do
off the side of my desk for fun
you know i meet somebody interesting a
friend starts a business
uh you know i'm kind of interested in an
area it's a way for me to make a small
bet it's a roulette chip
it's not something that i take very
seriously and
pitch hired you to sort of benchmark
their
your designs against the internal team's
design how did that
wind up going did you win or did the
internal team win or
did everything i think it was a bit of
both i think the meta lab team pushed
them and vice versa
to be honest i wasn't super involved
though uh in the actual day-to-day
you know we have so many businesses now
i can't be involved in individual
projects
which business is driving uh the most
revenue
and then the fastest growth right now in
this portfolio of 30 companies that
obviously includes dribble and we
mentioned flow the product management
software
we work remotely you bought from jason
freed and david hammer hanson over 37
signals i know that business was doing
well
as well what what business is doing
doing the best right now objectively
well i mean when we started we just had
the agency that was profitable
and we slowly started diversifying and
up until probably five or six years ago
the agency was still the largest thing
and now what we're seeing is
a lot of the other businesses are
reaching maturity and we're much more
well diversified and i would say i mean
dribble
since we acquired it we have i think
10 or 12x the revenue in
what is it five years um so we're
incredibly excited about what's
happening there
um and i mean there's lots of amazing
growth stories within we work remotely
i think we've 10x that business uh
what is the focal point of a business
like dribble is it 100 million dollars
in revenue 50 million in revenue what's
the what's the ball
tens of millions tens of millions when
you bought it what was it at
everybody knows dribble is a place just
you know single single digit
single digit millions wow um and so
somebody was running dribble as a side
hustle or as a business and they just
ran out of steam running it how do you
wind up buying something like that
well i think you talk to any founder in
year one and they say i love my business
i'm in it forever
i'm going to run it until i'm 80. and
then you talk to them
year five year six especially if their
business has done well and they've
started took some chips off the table
often they kind of start to slow down
often by year 8
10 they're kind of exhausted they want
to do something new they've got some new
ideas
and that's kind of where we come in so
with dribble for example
founders have been doing it for about
eight years they were a designer and a
developer
and they really loved building the
product but they didn't love doing
marketing hr support uh you know they
felt like they couldn't go on vacation
and they were just kind of exhausted
and so we basically came to them and we
said look why don't we buy 80
you guys keep 20 uh and we'll fight
really hard to make that 20
worth way more than you know if you'd
own the whole thing
and i think we've been successful in
doing that
and then what what is the outcome for a
business like that i mean the market is
incredibly hot right now
are you thinking about putting more
things together and taking them public
since our specs and the canadian market
seems to be
a little bit easier to go public on
companies can be smaller public on the
canadian market is that right
explain the difference between the two
markets
well in canada you can take a lot you
can take a business public a lot earlier
the regulatory environment is a little
less aggressive there's what's called a
venture exchange here where
you don't have to do quite as much
regulatory approval and all that kind of
stuff and then you can graduate
to be like being like a you know big
board kind of company
um we're considering taking more stuff
public but i mean to be honest
we just did this rto in december it's
called a reverse takeover instead of a
smack up here
and uh we're still evaluating i mean
it's been an incredible
outcome financially the valuation that
we've gotten has been
amazing this is for we commerce we're
talking about that for ecommerce but
yeah you know the the bet there was um
what is the marketing cap of
commerce it's about a billion dollars
canadian wow so weird when you look
these things up
on google in the stock market so this is
the over-the-counter market
in canada is that right the market yeah
it's not even it's not even
really trading in this data it's only
otc
got it so people can make trades but
they're generally like private trades
you wouldn't trade it on robinhood or
something
you have to use a broker it's not on
robinhood yet i think it we will be in
some a couple months got it so you can
do this over the counter thing
get people trading in the stock but then
to be
fully liquid on a big market
or on like trading platforms you have to
get off the otc is that what happens
yeah exactly so i mean with a business
like dribble
dribble doesn't really need capital it's
profitable it can keep reinvesting its
capital and growth we can make more
acquisitions and stuff and so
in order for us to take it public we
would need to see
an opportunity to buy you know something
really sizable
or see a massive growth opportunity
where we need tens of millions of
dollars of capital
um we just we just don't we haven't
needed it yet
got like a bad name in canada for a
while it's like oil companies and
drilling and
weird stuff right yeah there's a lot of
there's a lot of crap that goes public
this way
uh mining you know weird junior mining
companies or
food product companies with a million
dollars of revenue kind of stuff um
do you think that can be cleaned up and
do what chemoth did for spax but in
canada
is that like part of your vision for
this i think part of the reason we've
been rewarded
um so uh so well by the market has been
that
we came in and we've legitimized that in
a big way
i mean there were already sizable
companies going public via reverse
takeover
um but the fact we're bringing investors
like bill ackman and howard marks and
ryan graves the table i think
really bolstered it and we had a
business that was in a
extremely hot space you know shopify
e-commerce sas
and we had a consolidation play i think
people are really excited about it
because of that
and what was the revenue footprint there
for for something like we commerce
uh i think at the time we took a public
we're at maybe a 20 million dollar run
rate
wow and so it's obviously doing a little
bit better now i would assume
but 50 times revenue pretty amazing for
for evaluation yeah i mean we try and
ignore
the valuation to be honest like it's
kind of a distraction we're just focused
on
making good investments and putting one
foot in front of the other
do you like the ad businesses the ad
based businesses or
are those challenging for you to run it
seems like a lot of your stuff is
subscription based and membership based
but do you like the ad business as well
well no i mean we looked at um
we actually looked at morning brew and
the hustle
and many other newsletter businesses and
i think they're incredible
incredible businesses they're like the
modern day newspaper
but the issue i always had with them is
that at the end of the day
ad rates can change and when one line on
your p
l can just drop by 50 because a number
changes
you know a cpm rate changes or something
that's a little scary
um and the amount of head count required
to sell ads and stuff
freaks me out a little bit but i don't
think they're bad businesses necessarily
i just think
you have to be careful if you're buying
one you can't pay too much and make the
assumption that
today's ad rates will stay the same for
10 years they might drop by 70
they might go up by 20 they're
unpredictable got it yeah it's it's
super tied to what's happening in the
market and so hustle
that sold to hubspot uh
for something like 30 million bucks or
something did that include trends.com or
was that
two separate businesses i wonder and
then insider business insider bought
morning brew is that right
yeah i think i think that encompassed
everything
including again they're great i mean i
love the founders of both those
businesses
they're um they're phenomenal businesses
and i think they got great deals so i'm
super excited for them
30 million is a great deal yeah i mean
it felt like trends was doing
maybe 10 million dollars in business
what was it doing do you think i don't
know
it was millions of it must have been
millions of dollars in business so
maybe they got five times revenue if
they were doing five
i can't i mean i was under nda oh right
right but um you should have sam
looks like trends was at two million is
uh what sam reported recently uh one of
my researchers told me
so that's pretty good and then hustle
you know maybe a couple million and then
yeah 10 times revenue that makes sense
what did morning brew get sold for i
wonder
i don't know it's publicly reported at
60 or something oh okay
75 million i heard yeah so that's pretty
amazing
i wonder what their re they broke 10
million in revenue i think
in ad revenue i'm not sure but you you
think subscription businesses are better
than ad businesses those are the
preferred ones you like to buy
yeah i mean generally i like a business
if it's not recurring i want it to be
kind of frictionless so for example
you know a job board we work remotely
for example it's not recurring
necessarily there are recurring
aspects to it like when you buy a job
it'll recur for 30 days
a few times but at the end of the day
um you know it's still a digital
transaction
but it is frictionless people come to
your site they self-serve
and they buy an ad and that's a lot
better than having to have an ad sales
team or a job sales team that goes out
calls all the hiring managers and tries
to sell them individual jobs
just it scales much better yeah if
people can just
go and and buy a job i think we work
remotely it's like three or four hundred
bucks for a job posting is that right
that's the upper bound of what you can
charge i guess
yeah with all the fixings i think it can
come out over 500